bonjour après les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement à birmingham ce sera au
tour des ministres de l'environnement
des douze de se retrouver après demain à
luxembourg cinq des ministres d'ailleurs
qui participeront à cette réunion s'est
d'ailleurs présent ce matin dans ce
studio autour de monsieur jacques delors
et de madame ségolène royal alors
réunion importante madame dans la mesure
où la défense de l'environnement est un
des domaines dans lequel peut se
construire cette europe plus proche des
citoyens que le sommet de birmingham a
appelé de ses voeux la lord par
définition l'environnement n'a pas de
frontière et se prêtent par conséquent
très bien aux décisions supranationale
alors à luxembourg vous parlerez
naturellement de cette question des
déchets industriels notamment des
déchets toxiques sur lequel vous avez
ameuter l'opinion française le mois
dernier en cherchant à faire interdire
leur traitement du pyralène australien
en france sans succès et votre échec que
pose d'ailleurs le problème de vote au
pouvoir réel au sein du gouvernement un
pouvoir que 70% des français
souhaiteraient plus large qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui si l'on en croit le sondage
publié ce matin par le journal du
dimanche alors arlette chabot chef du
service politique de france 2 on parlera
avec vous vous êtes socialiste ou
succéder à un ministre écologiste que ce
que ça change vous êtes jeune quel
regard portez-vous quel jugement
portez-vous sur la vie politique et sur
ses archaïsmes albert du roy vous
demandera ensuite votre avis sur
quelques grands problèmes de la société
contemporaine puce vous parlerez de vous
aux cibles et maintenant commencer par
les affaires de votre ministère qui
couvre déjà un champ extrêmement vaste
nous en parlerons avec jean marie
colombani parlerons des décisions que
vous êtes en train de préparer pour
faire entrer dans les faits à la fois le
sommet de rio 2 juin de juin dernier et
le traité de maastricht qui prévoit dans
son article 2 que les deux devront
trouver les voies d'une croissance
durable et non inflationniste respectant
l'environnement leur vaste projet nous
allons voir tout ça dossier par dossier
en commençant peut-être par les
dramatiques inondations du vaucluse une
vengeance de la nature dont on connaît
depuis hier
la facture financières exorbitantes 710
millions de francs
je vais demander à jean marie colombani
de venir s'installer à mes paroles qui
s'installe je vais vous demander comment
vous voulez vous qu'on vous appelle
madame le ministre madame la milice
écouté que cette question fasse encore
l'objet de plaisanteries en dit long sur
l'évolution des mentalités je crois que
c'est parfois aux petites choses que
l'on voit l'état des mentalités dans un
pays vous savez il ya belle lurette que
chez nos amis et voisins jeu voilà ma
collègue de belgique on l'appelle la
ministre sans problème en italie la
ministre à la cena ti street chien il ya
très longtemps
en france on est encore un peu comment
dirais-je peut-être mentalité de la
haute-egypte où une femme pharaon
hatshepsout est représenté sur les
bas-reliefs avec une barbe pour bien
montrer que le pouvoir est un attribut
masculin
donc moi je n'ai pas honte de vous
résumer se dévouent même que dans la
note de service que vous avez fait pour
demander qu'on vous appelle madame la
ministre vous l'avait adressée à
messieurs les directeurs de centrales
c'est un top 10 n avait jamais de femmes
heureusement tu connais mes directeurs
d'administration centrale ce sont tous
des saints cela dit bon chaque jour
apporte et son progrès dans les
mentalités avec jean marie colombani
bien alors vaison-la-romaine ça a été
une catastrophe nationale
on va pas vous imputer la météo pas plus
qu'à vous pouvez trouver le vaucluse le
vaucluse et puis les pyrénées et l'aude
mais tout le reste dépend de l'homme la
façon dont on canalise on ne canalise
pas les pluies les autres pluie
l'endroit où on construit les routes
l'endroit où on décide dessine les
périmètres pour construire les maisons
les emplacements de camping
alors quel est le comment dire quelle
est la réaction du gouvernement par
rapport à toute cette toutes ces
courriels de problèmes en cascade
tout dépend de l'homme pas tout à fait
je crois que la catastrophe de
vaison-la-romaine précisément si elle
était aussi terrible s'est bien passé
bien à cause de sa violence inouïe nous
avons gardé les archives et nous avons
vu que pour retrouver un phénomène de
mousson de cette importance là il
fallait remonter à 14 140
donc je crois que personne ne pouvait
prévoir cette violence mais notre
responsabilité c'est d'essayer de
limiter les dégâts et de prévenir autant
que l'on peut se tourner les yeux vers
les années récentes on
on a l'impression que ce genre de
catastrophes s'accélère parce que nîmes
c'était ça n'était pas si anciens et on
al'impression également que et bien
malgré tout les les élus et les
décideurs les promoteurs à tous ceux qui
ont une décision à prendre sont assez
inattentif parce que personne n'imagine
jamais devoir subir ce type de deux
fléaux donc c'est ça la difficulté en
plus je crois que l'on ne peut pas
maîtriser tous les éléments de la nature
on cherche toujours chaque fois qu'il ya
une catastrophe naturelle des
responsabilités et bien non parfois la
nature à des puissances qui n'est pas
celle de l'homme cela dit je crois qu'il
faut en tirer les leçons de cette
catastrophe de vaison la romaine car
effectivement il ya 52 communes qui ont
été identifiés comme étant en situation
de grande fragilité de grands dangers et
le ministère de l'environnement qui est
chargée de la prévention des risques
majeurs va tirer les leçons de cette
catastrophe et l'on veut c'est à dire
d'abord nous avons envoyé discrètement
parce que c'est pas la peine aujourd'hui
et je crois que l'urgence était c'est de
penser les plaies il ya 7000 familles
vous parliez du bilan il ya 7000
familles en situation de grande
difficulté aujourd'hui donc je crois que
pour en tirer les leçons au plan de la
prévention faut d'abord respecter les
victimes et le faire au moment opportun
mais ce que nous allons faire avec le
ministère de l'environnement et le
ministre de l'equipement jean louis
bianco c'est que d'abord nous avons
envoyé trois inspecteurs sur place trois
ingénieurs qui rendront leur rapport
dans un mois ce rapport sera rendu
immédiatement public est pas un an après
comme après la catastrophe de nîmes
deuxièmement les français ont droit à
être informé c'est écrit dans la loi ce
qui me choque c'est qu'on puisse arriver
dans un camping s'installer et ne pas
savoir que ce camping est en zone
inondable
là il ya un vrai respect de la vie
humaine donc s'est donnée une obligation
de résultat au préfet qui vont contrôler
la façon dont les maires vont implanter
des panneaux d'affichage indique en zone
inondable mais je vais arrêter la
dimension du panneau d'affichage que ça
ne soit pas collé derrière alain parce
que c'est vrai que ce n'est pas
économiquement porteur d'être en zone
inondable y compris pour les promotions
immobilières donc obligation d'affichage
avec des dimensions sur les affiches
élisant une intensité dans
l'implantation de ces affiches
ensuite je suis en train de préparer un
d
et pour donner aux préfets le pouvoir
d'interdire les campings en zone
inondable
car là aussi il n'est pas possible que
des vies humaines soit entre les mains
de quelqu'un qui tient un camping donc
il faut que l'état assume ses
responsabilités en matière de sécurité
c'est ça le rôle d'un ministère de
l'environnement c'est de veiller à la
sécurité
il ya deux autres points qui sont
beaucoup plus sensibles c'est le
problème des plans d'exposition au sol
des plans d'exposition au risque et donc
des plans d'occupation des sols
ces plans d'exposition risque qui avait
été recommandé dans le rapport qui avait
suivi la catastrophe de nîmes ont mis du
temps à se mettre en place pourquoi
parce que ça coûte cher et parce que
c'est compliqué donc ce que nous allons
faire avec le ministre de l'équipement
s'est renforcé la charge de la preuve
c'est à dire établir des zones sujettes
à risques y mettre les réglementations
d'interdiction de construction est
appliquée seulement après les études qui
permettront de lever les interdictions
et pas l'effet inverse
enfin le dernier point difficile avec
lequel j'ai longuement parlé avec le
maire de vaison la romaine
c'est le suivant va-t-on autoriser les
citoyens à reconstruire au même endroit
là où les maisons étaient déconstruite
la réponse est aujourd'hui les familles
ne veulent pas réhabilités dans ces
maisons là mais les assurances
n'indemnise que la reconstruction à
l'endroit où les murs se sont écroulés
dès lors que les fondations sont restés
en place les assurances n'indemnise que
les que les murs et le toit à remettre
aux fondations veut dire qu'il ya
construit enfin donc ça c'est pas que
c'est pas normal donc il faut matin en
place un interlocuteur un pool des
assureurs et permettre aux familles les
indemniser suffisamment pour qu'elle me
reconstruise pas au même endroit bien
voilà on va quitter ce vaison la romaine
pour aborder le sommet de luxembourg
dont françois henry a parlé tout à
l'heure et pour n'en retenir qu'un
aspect de l'ordre du jour celui des
déchets parce que vous êtes signaler à
l'attention de l'opinion à propos de
cette affaire de déchets hospitaliers et
les problèmes de décharges sauvages
puis il ya eu la sphère du pyralène
australien et le démenti que vous a
infligé le gouvernement et enfin au scan
oui et vient maintenant devant nous
cette semaine même
on attend l'arrivée d'un bateau japonais
chargés de re de rapatrier du plutonium
de l'usiné de la hague vers le japon
avec probablement des manifestations de
greenpeace tu es une demande de la part
des écologistes qui est en matière de
plutonium de tout arrêter de stocker au
fond le plutonium tel qu'il est à la
hague pour lancer une vaste réflexion
sur les risques du plutonium alors
quelle va être votre votre attitude par
rapport à ce problème de déchets je
pense que l'action d'un mise de
l'environnement doit s'inscrire dans la
durée c'est à dire un mise de
l'environnement doit essayer de prévoir
ce qui va se passer dans quelle
direction vont les normes
il doit aussi où elle doit aussi
s'appliquer s'appuyer sur des principes
clairs en ce qui concerne le problème
des déchets les principes sont clairs
ils ont à la fois été réaffirmé lors du
sommet de rio dans l'agenda 21
ce sont des principes de proximité deux
précautions et d'autosuffisance c'est ce
que nous avons appliqué à propos des
déchets allemands précaution c'est ça
veut dire qu'il faut limiter les
mouvements déchets sinon il ya des
trafics proximité ça veut dire qu'il
faut traiter les déchets à proximité de
l'endroit où il s'en produit
autosuffisant ça veut dire que chaque
pays est responsable de ces profondeurs
le principe d'auto suffisance on l'a vu
à propos du pyralène australien il
s'oppose à une autre donnée forte qui
est économique c'est là qu'est que la
france par exemple dispose d'une
technologie adaptée au retraitement du
pyralène comme elle dispose d'une
technologie adaptée au retraitement des
déchets nucléaires et que si elle
dispose de cette technologie pour la
rentabiliser elle va devoir accueillir
des déchets venant non seulement de
l'intérieur de la communauté mais au
delà de la communauté alors comment vous
allez concilier ce principe d'auto
suffisance avec les nécessités
économiques qui tiennent à l'existence
d'une technologie française
l'autosuffisance
elle doit s'appliquer pays par pays
lorsqu'il s'agit des déchets ménagers
ont produit nos épluchures de pommes de
terre chaque pays est un pâle de mettre
en place des décharges des systèmes
d'accélération pour traiter ces déchets
là les déchets industriels c'est déjà
plus compliqué schaper ne peut pas avoir
la technologie
pays par pays pour traiter parce qu'il
ya des investissements très lourds à
faire parce qu'il ya des technologies de
pointe à faire à ce moment là le
principe doit texto suffisance au niveau
des continents c'est à dire qu'il faut
quand même rester ferme sur les
principes de non transport d'un bout à
l'autre de la planète de déchets
dangereux
pourquoi parce que dès que les déchets
sont baladés sur une longue distance
les bateaux font escale dans les pays du
tiers monde pour y déverser des
cochonneries et c'est donc ça c'est dans
la convention de bâle
c'est dans la directive européenne c'est
dans les conclusions du sommet de la
planète terre à rio et moi en tant que
miss de l'environnement je dois être
ferme sur ses principes
car il faut que l'on établisse pour la
gestion de la planète des règles claires
d'organisation du transport des déchets
qui sont à la source d'une des premières
nuisances de la planète
donc revenons en aux pcb australien ma
position c'est de dire il faut que les
continents ce équipe et donc la poésie
la france doit équiper l'australie
vendre sa technologie
c'est bon pour l'emploi en france c'est
bon pour la présence de l'industrie
française dans cette partie du globe et
c'est bon pour la protection de la
planète quatre car personne ne peut
justifier qu'on puisse aller chercher à
l'autre bout du globe des déchets pour
être traités en france
la france n'est pas la machine à laver
du monde entier donc chaque pays doit
prendre ses responsabilités et quand
j'ai eu la ministre australienne au
téléphone car qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
le bateau de pcb est arrivé il a été
refoulé par les anglais il a été refoulé
par les belges il a été accepté par la
france première question d'une ministre
française de l'environnement
pourquoi acceptons ce que les autres
pays européens n'accepte pas car dans
les autres nommés et la dominique
strauss kahn qui est votre collègue de
l'industrie a répondu parce que nous
avons une technologie sur place qui apte
à traiter ce genre de chose et que ça
rapporte des devises au pays et un
contrat mais samedi voilà qu'on trempe
entre lui et sa justice
la technologie on peut l'avant la
technologie alors la ministre sera
immédiat même et écologistes ne veulent
pas qu'on installe des usines
d'incinération d'australie inacceptables
inacceptables
chaque continent doit traiter ses
propres affaires au revoir
s'il y avait un contrat ce qui veut dire
qu arbitrage du premier ministre il
s'appuie quand même sur quelque chose
qui qui est acceptable
c'est l'exécution des contrats en cours
des contrats qui ont été signés
ça veut dire 700 tonnes pour l'australie
200 tonnes pour la nouvelle-zélande
mais au delà au delà il ya encore vingt
mille tonnes à traiter en australie et
moi je ne signerai aucun autre nouveau
contrat car je veux que nos intellos
riel a équipé de là on a parlé beaucoup
du père l'aisne mais la question qui va
être dans tous les esprits cette semaine
c'est le plutonium produit éminemment
dangereux qui ressort des usines de l'
usine de retraitement de la hague alors
quelle va être votre position par
rapport à il est qu'on retrouve dans les
coffres de voiture apparemment non on
trouve de l'uranium dans les coffres de
voitures allemand mais c'est mais là ces
gens circulent quoi voilà il s'agit là
alors vous disiez ne pas transporter sur
les longues distances le bateau va
arriver à cherbourg pour repartir vers
le japon chargée d'une tonne de
plutonium
alors qu'on sait qu'un microgrammes de
plutonium est excessivement dangereux et
la position fera la même serre je pense
que le transport de matières dangereuses
sur longue distance n'est pas un progrès
pour la planète mais qu'aujourd'hui de
quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit d'un retour vers le japon de
son plutonium
je préfère que le japon récupère son
plutonium plutôt que celui ci reste en
france c'est le premier point
deuxième observation c'est que les
japonais sont en train de construire une
usine de retraitement
donc nous nous acheminons vers
l'autosuffisance donc ces principes là
il respecte est donc à la fois proximité
parce que c'est vrai que c'est pas un
progrès autosuffisance parce que les
japonais sont en train de l'équipe et et
enfin retour des déchets ultimes vers
l'envoyeur c'est eux c'est aussi un
grand principe qui a été affirmé au plan
international bien il ya un troisième
grand dossier qui est sur vos sur votre
bureau vous avait d'ailleurs déposé ou
vous n'allez pas tarder à déposer sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale s'essuie
du paysage puisqu'on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui du paysage du paysage rural
etc
comment allez vous gérer cette affaire
parce que là encore vous et vous situé
au coeur d'une contradiction tout à
l'heure entre le contradiction entre
l'industrie l'environnement avec le
problème du paysage contradiction entre
les logiques d'urbanisation et leur la
protection d'un patrimoine paysager
comment abordez vous cette question à
mes yeux la politique du paysage c'est
pourquoi c'est une priorité majeure
parce que j'observe que chaque fois que
la nature est souillée chaque fois que
les paysages sont dégradées ce sont les
hommes et les femmes qui sont méprisés
donc la protection et la reconquête des
paysages c'est un combat social majeur
et tout converge vers la la propreté de
l'eau la propreté de l'air le respect
que l'on met dans la façon dont on
construit les choses
la protection de l'espace rural
l'équilibré entre le rural et l'urbain
tout cela converge vers les paysages
donc pour moi c'est un combat social
majeur c'est une question d'égalité des
chances majeur devant la nature car ceux
qui ont du pouvoir on le voit bien quand
il ya des conflits autour des grandes
infrastructures
ceux qui ont des pouvoirs ceux qui
arrivent à s'organiser ce sont en
général les gens cultivés les gens qui
ont des moyens ils arrivent à protéger
leur environnement
les autres sont trop pris par les
problèmes de la vie quotidienne le
chauffage en même temps à l'éducation
des enfants et donc ma responsabilité
c'est de répondre à cette inégalité
temps à l'heure de la décentralisation
on a du mal à imaginer ce qu'on peut
mettre dans une loi pour protéger quoi
pour figer le paysage français non au
contraire je pense que le paysage c'est
à la fois le passé c'est à dire ça à la
fois l'histoire notre histoire notre
géographie mais c'est aussi une notion
très moderne c'est à dire qu'il faut la
reconquérir
il faut les reconquérir ses paysages en
ville il faut préserver leur leurs
auteurs
leur spécificité leur authenticité en
milieu rural il faut reconquérir les
entrées de bourg les entrées de ville
les paysages de rivière il faut remettre
de l'espace dans les villes car
aujourd'hui le paysage il est vu en
creux c'est ce qui n'est pas construit
c'est ça qu'il faut changer lever une
armée de paysagistes vous allez recours
et bien j avais plus des paysagistes en
france ce serait bien reconverti je vais
je vais faire un permis paysage et c'est
à dire un volet paysager au permis de
construire pour changer les mentalités
je vais mettre un volet paysager
obligatoirement dans les plans
d'occupation des sols pour que les
collectivités humaines réfléchissent à
ce qu'est leur identité paysagère
je vais créer des directives nationales
du paysage pour que l'on puisse avoir un
outil plus souple que les classements
qui sont trop rigides mais qu'ils
puissent désigner à l'ensemble de
l'opinion publique
quels sont les paysages qui constitue
notre patrimoine commun
merci jean marie colombani leur
calendrier tout ça parce que les gens se
disent évidemment qu'ils nous écoutent
en mars rocha vous ne serez provence
plus au gouvernement quand est-ce que ça
va être voté par les députés
la à cette session le premier ministre
vitré à la fois le projet de loi sur le
bruit et le projet de loi sur les
paysages
ils seront donc présentés à cette
cession va pas parler du bruit on en
parlera peut-être thaler arlette chabot
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
différence entre un ministre de
l'environnement et que le gist façon
brice lalonde et un ministre de
l'environnement socialiste comme vous
écoutez moi ce que je souhaite c'est
être jugé à mon action et cette
action-là jeu langage dans un projet
global de société
ce qui m'intéresse pour l'environnement
s'est pas seulement pour protéger la
faune la flore les animaux c'est
protéger l'homme c'est de protéger
pour moi l'écologie c'est d'abord un
humanisme et ce qui me préoccupe c'est
la réduction des inégalités devant
l'environnement c'est comme cela que
j'ai choisi mes priorités ce qui me
préoccupe aussi c'est à la fois la
recherche d'un équilibre et finalement
c'est au coeur de la politique c'est le
coeur de la construction d'un nouveau
d'un nouveau modèle de société ou de
développement
c'est la recherche des équilibres les
équilibres au niveau des territoires les
équilibres au niveau des générations les
équilibres au niveau des peuples c'est
ce qu'on a vu au sommet de la planète
terre à rio
et donc si je voulais résumer d'un mot
moi je suis une sociale écologiste
sociales écologistes socialistes non on
peut plus dire que les socialistes
aujourd'hui si je suis socialiste parce
que je ne veux pas renier d'où je viens
et c'est pas au moment où les
socialistes vont mal que je quitterai
cette étiquette
j'ai jamais tellement été aimé par les
socialistes que ce soit au plan local ou
au plan national
et pourtant c'est pas aujourd'hui où ça
va mal ou je vois tant d'hommes qui ont
été au fond des secteurs du socialisme
le quitter aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
justement en ce moment que j'ai envie
d'y rester
pourquoi parce que dans le socialisme
finalement c'est peut-être un des maux
les plus beaux qu'ils puissent exister
c'est tout simplement la conviction que
l'homme doit s'améliorer que la société
doit s'améliorer que les inégalités
doivent reculer qu'il y a un projet
social majeur que l'état a un rôle à
jouer tout cela c'est le socialisme mais
c'est vrai que les français n'acceptent
plus les mots en isme je crois que
depuis la chute du mur de berlin il ya
avant le mur après le mur comme il y
avait avant 14 après gâteurs socialisme
ça ne passe plus donc il faut qu'on y
réfléchisse alors je voudrais savoir
quelques questions sur sur l'écologie
sur votre action disais tout à l'heure
70% des français souhaiteraient par
exemple que vous ayez davantage du
pouvoir mettre de pression pour
l'instant que c'est un peu l'écologie
une façon de faire des cadeaux
aujourd'hui à cette affaire des barrages
de la loire on les a supprimées pour
faire plaisir ouvert 10 et 11 ans
aujourd'hui ont rétabli un barrage beach
à mon cher pour faire plaisir aux
communistes alors est-ce qu'au fond vous
n'êtes pas là pour faire la pêche aux
voix une fois du côté des verts une fois
chez les communistes la pêche aux voix
tout dépend ce qu'on entend par la pêche
aux voix
s'il s'agit de travailler pour
l'environnement des français de faire en
sorte qu'ils se disent que le travail du
gouvernement a été bien et donc il faut
le soutenir tant mieux mais en ce qui
concerne le barrage de chambonchard moi
je trouve très choquant le procès
d'intention qui a été fait car peut-on
imaginer que je puisse accepter de
sacrifier l'environnement nom d'une
cause qui n'aurait rien à voir avec elle
mais on aurait demandé une chose
pareille mais j'aurais quitté le
gouvernement
donc c'est pas pour faire plaisir aux
députés qu'on a mal et a même barrage de
chambonchard l'arbitrage qui a été rendu
par edith cresson n'est pas remise en
cause
ce qui change aujourd'hui c'est que de
toute façon la loi sur l'eau à perdre il
que l'on fasse de gros barrages
on ne gère pu la ressource en eau comme
on le faisait il ya cinq ou même via il
ya trois ou quatre ans aujourd'hui de
quoi s'agit-il
la situation était complètement bloquée
sur le terrain complètement les lots
pour les associations ne se parlaient
plus quand il ya une dégradation du
dialogue social qu'est ce qu'on fait on
s'arqueboutent on retrouve le dialogue
on trouve le dialogue c'est ce que
pierre bérégovoy a décidé c'est ce qui a
été fait dans le cas d'une commission
denquête qui travaillent en toute
transparence
l'étude d'impact sur rouge bucs avait
décidé le précédent gouvernement il y
avait décidé de faire route but est de
ne pas faire chambonchard aujourd'hui
nous remettons sur la table rouge but
qui restent les études se poursuivent
elle me seront donnés à la fin du mois
je les mettrai sur la table on verra ce
que ça donne elles n'étaient pas toutes
bonnes pour l'environnement les
décisions relatives à rouge but et l'on
va comparer avec un petit barrage à
chambonchard c'est une idée que n'a pas
eue le gouvernement c'est une idée qui
est née de la commission denquête et les
associations de protection de la nature
notamment loire vivante qui sont des
associations remarquable et responsable
on était d'accord pour la réouverture du
dialogue donc rendez vous fin novembre
pour l'étude d'impact sur roche but
rendez vous fin décembre
pour la comparaison entre les deux
petits barrages et l'on verra ses procès
d'intention qui a été fait au premier
ministre est fondée ou non pour
regretter qu'il ait pas de véritables
écologistes gouvernement avec vous
certains ne soit pas rentrée à
l'occasion du remaniement par exemple
oui bien sûr parce que je pense qu'ils
apportent quelque chose d'important à la
vie politique française
j'ai la conviction que les valeurs de
protection de l'environnement sont des
valeurs collectives c'est un patrimoine
commun que l'on défend et que par
conséquent il y a elles sont pour ce
sont des valeurs de progrès et les
valeurs de protection de l'environnement
donc je pense oui que nous devons
travailler ensemble alors je reviens au
socialisme et à votre engagement
quel est votre originalité aujourd'hui
quel est votre différence entre votre
génération est celle par exemple qui a
fondé le parti socialiste celui des pink
quel est votre message que les autres
originalités
je pense que c'est difficile parce que
pourquoi serait ton meilleur que les
anciens je pensais aux différents moi je
crois que c'est l'action qui nous qui
nous différencie je pense que le monde
change vite on arrive on arrive dans un
système politique qui a perdu ses points
de repères c'est dû probablement à
l'effondrement aussi du communisme à
l'est
donc nous sommes devant une
reconstruction à faire dont il faut
retrouver des idées tout en restant
fidèles à nos valeurs aux valeurs de la
gauche aux valeurs des forces de progrès
mais en même temps tout reste à à
reconstruire et aujourd'hui je devais
deux trois idées à développer on pas
faire un programme parce qu'on appelle
temps mais deux trois points forts de
trois valeurs auxquelles vous vous
référez vraiment aujourd'hui je pense
que les valeurs fondamentales ce sont
les valeurs du partage ait valeur d
équilibre et il faut ré inscrire la
politique dans le temps c'est ce que
fait d'ailleurs l'environnement moi j'y
suis plus porté que d'autres parce que
chaque fois que nous prenons une
décision que je prends une décision sans
engagent le long terme ça engage des
générations futures
il faut ré inscrire la politique dans le
temps lui redonner des perspectives et
il faut s'arc bouter sur la recherche
des équilibres
en gros nous serons jugés sur quoi
disons que c'est si on résume un peu
l'état de la société française comme des
sociétés européennes
il ya un groupe centre a à peu près 7
français sur 10 qui vivent moyennement
qui vivent correctement il ya 10 % de
français qui vivent bien et très bien et
puis à 20% qui sont très fragiles
ou attirés vers la pauvreté quel est
l'enjeu majeur de la politique
aujourd'hui c'est de se dire que les
enfants de ces 20% là doivent pouvoir
grimper au dessus grâce à l'éducation
grâce à la promotion
donc tout ce que l'on mettra en place
qui permettra aux enfants de ses 20% la
fragiliser des banlieues des villages
pauvres ou même des problèmes du tiers
monde c'est la même chose on tout ce qui
permettra à ces 20% là de d'avoir
l'espoir de grimper c'est essentiel et
pour le groupe central tout ce qui
permettra de consolider leur sécurité
leurs acquis mais aussi le mais aussi
leurs espoirs vers quelque chose de fort
la politique elle doit aussi redonner
une fierté de la pensée c'est à dire
répondre à la fois problèmes concrets et
rebela progrès de la science du pouvoir
alors êtes vous pensez qu en
réintroduisant la durée dans la
politique vous ferez mieux ressortir les
différences entre une gestion de gauche
et une gestion de droite sur le long
terme sera visible plus visible bien sûr
des décisions au jour le jour
bien sûr pourquoi parce que il faut pour
pour gérer dans la durée il faut aussi
que l'état donc que les valeurs
collectives prennent le dessus par
rapport à la loi du marché
la loi du marché elle règle les choses
immédiate on l'a vu sur le pc
d'australia la loi du marché c'était le
respect des contrats le respect d'une
entreprise c'était légitime aussi le
choix du long terme c'est de se dire
mais ouvrons les yeux demain ça ne sera
plus possible de transporter des mac
c'est pareil c'est vraiment
l'illustration que l'environnement doit
être visionnaire la politique doit être
visionnaire elle doit voir le monde dans
cinq dix ans dire aux français voilà
comment nous voyons le monde dans 5 ou
10 ans et redonner cette fierté de la
pensée est ce que vous êtes touchés
n'ont pas concerné directement mais un
peu sans doute catastrophé par la crise
morale qui semble traverser le parti
socialiste les affaires est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya eu un certain laisser
aller chez vos amis
oui ça me fait mal ça me fait mal
surtout ça me fait mal pour les
militants parce que je crois qu'il ya
une grande désespérance des militants
socialistes qui sont là depuis longtemps
qu'ils croient qui est je crois qu'il
faut reconstruire reconstruire cela
c'est aussi ce que nous essayons de
faire dans ce club témoin si parce que
la politique ce n'est pas seulement être
candidats des élections
la politique c'est retrouver des lieux
deux débats s'est retrouvé des lieux de
convivialité sir réfléchir aux valeurs
qui nous animent
si vous devez opter - par exemple votre
club ça veut dire qu'on va exécuter ce
sont un certain nombre effectivement de
jeunes comme andy du parti socialiste
que vous aussi des intellectuels qui se
retrouvent autour de jacques delors et
qui vont effectivement essayé d'élaborer
un stand de propositions pour l'avenir
si on crée ces clubs de marche du parti
socialiste ça veut dire qu'on peut plus
discuter il ya plus d'idées possible ou
presque
non c'est qu'il est je pense prisonniers
des échéances électorales comme tout
parti car il s'occupe des désignations
aux prochaines élections c'est so c'est
aussi son rôle et je pense aussi parce
qu'il est il est déserté par les
militants le parti socialiste n'a pas
évolué qui fonctionne comme il ya encore
quarante ou cinquante ans il n'a pas vu
qu'il y avait la télévision il n'a pas
vu qu'il y avait une aspiration à la
conviviale noyer le jeune premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
oui mais je pense qu'il est très occupé
par les par les échéances électorales et
la politique ce ne sont pas que les
échéances électorales donc il faut
redonner des idées à la gauche et c'est
ça c'est pro donne et des vitamines
redonner des lieux de débat il ya une
aspiration extraordinaire pourquoi
trouvez ces lieux de débat alors on
parle un petit peu quand même justement
le problème électoral est ce que vous
souhaitez une alliance électorale ferme
avec les écologistes pour les prochaines
législatives sur un programme jusqu'à
présent le gfa bus avait proposé à ses
membres de circonscription ça n'a pas
très bien été reçu effectivement par les
verts ou par génération écologique a
refusé les propositions il faut qu il
faut conclure un programme et à quel
prix je pense déjà que c'est pas en se
promenant des circonscriptions sous le
bras qu'on va conclure des alliances
donc je crois que les alliances elles
peuvent se faire sur un programme
c'est un peu aussi l'échec de
l'ouverture d'une certaine façon et des
ouvertures vers des personnalités mais
pas vers de véritables forces et pas sur
la base de véritables programmes jean
pierre soisson par exemple par exemple
une bonne idée si c'est une ouverture
vers une personnalité mais qui ne ça ne
repose pas sur une véritable force
politique ni sur un programme donc ça
c'est de ce point de vue là ça a été
trop court mais parce qu'il n'y avait
pas eu de possibilité de faire autre
chose personne n'est venu pour un pour
accepter donc c'est cette ouverture sur
la base d'une alliance solide
donc je crois qu'il faut d'abord
construire cette plateforme conjointe
ça s'est fait entre les verts et les
socialistes dans le nord pas de calais
ça prouve que donc c'est possible donc
je crois aussi avec des voeux
et un président d'opposition udf en
lorraine
oui mais si vous regardez la différence
entre les deux accords d'un côté vous
avez un programme de société de gestion
de la région qui n'est pas limitée aux
problèmes d'environnement qui s'étend
aux problèmes de développement durable
sur la région de lutte contre les
inégalités de transparence car c'est
très important la façon dont on procède
aujourd'hui avec les citoyens et en
région lorraine vous n'avez rien vous
n'avez d'accord aucun programme c'est un
accord partisans donc ça les lorrains
jugeront c'est leur affaire
ouvert de lorraine mais la différence
est considérable
donc vous dites vrai lecteur le
programme et je disais à quel prix est
allé en kilomètres d'autoroutes en moins
aux constructions diversion parce qu'il
faut accepter qu est ce qui est accepté
avec qu'est ce qui ne l'est pas moi je
pense que la protection de
l'environnement ne se négocie pas comme
comme des bouts de chandelles je pense
que il faut se mettre d'accord sur les
vraies valeurs et ses vraies valeurs
c'est celle que je donne tout à l'heure
comment produire autrement comment
veiller d'abord aux hommes par rapport
au paysage croire protéger la faune et
la flore ça n'a aucun intérêt si on doit
construire des campagnes vide par
exemple aucun intérêt donc le vrai
problème c'est l'équilibré humain s'est
montré que l'environnement c'est aussi
un humanisme donc c'est sur ces valeurs
là qu'il faut que nous mettions d'accord
et pas en pinaillant sur un nombre de
kilomètres d'autoroutes d'un mot vous
sentez plus proche aujourd'hui les
écologistes que des communistes c'est ce
qu'il faut conclure un accord ils
essaient de sens plus proche des
écologistes que des communistes où il
vaut mieux sacrifier entre guillemets
les communistes pour conclure des
accords avec les verts
écoutez je crois que tout le monde est
bienvenu dans la recomposition d'une
grande d'un grand mouvement du progrès
tout le monde il y à la fois la
tradition mutualiste ouvrière il ya à la
fois la tradition républicaine pour
l'intervention de l'état
il ya la tradition démocrate-chrétienne
de la charité qui passe de l'abbé pierre
jusqu'à la démocratie chrétienne il ya
la tradition internationaliste il ya la
tradition laïque qui veut que personne
ne reste de côté quels que soient ses
convictions il ya tout cela à faire
converger dans une grande force de
mouvement donc tout le monde ya sa place
alors jacques delors est là aujourd'hui
tout le monde a pu le voir déjà
est-ce que vous avez oublié d'inviter
michel rocard ou ce qui n'était pas
disponible aujourd'hui
ou pour dire les choses très clairement
est-ce que vous souhaitez que jacques de
leur accès à d'autres responsabilités
pour les français écoutez ce que je
crois de façon jacques delors et là
aussi parce que je crois qu'en politique
il faut être fidèle
moi je suis à la fois fidèle à jacques
delors qui nous est depuis cinq ou six
ans souvenez-vous de l'épopée des
transcourants est là nous n'étions pas
en odeur de sainteté
fidèle à françois mitterrand parce que
c'est lui qui m'a initié à la politique
fidèle à pierre bérégovoy parce qu'il
est le premier ministre qui m'a choisie
dans son gouvernement et que l'échéance
maintenant ce sont des échéances
législatives
ce ne sont pas des échéances
présidentielles de toute façon qui va
choisir le candidat ce sera l'opinion
publique qui choisira le camp de plus le
sondage pps non plus ce sondage que non
plus plus les français
qu'un parti qui de toute façon comme
tous les partis ont beaucoup de travail
à faire de vente pour reconquérir la
confiance des citoyens
merci arlette chabot on enchaîne avec
albert du roy
même avant de revenir à des problèmes
politico des problèmes d'écologie ou
d'environnement
je voudrais avoir des nouvelles du bébé
d'abord qu'est ce que vous voulez me
dire monsieur durand
je vais vous dire si ces nouvelles du
bébé posez votre question je m'en
doutais bien ça va bien merci
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu raison de monter
enfin voila vous n'aviez pas vrai c'est
au moins de moitié on voit on a vu sur
toutes les terres du colza ou le
quatrième la naissance soit pas la
naissance mais le bébé à peine né oui
est-ce que c'était un dérapage de l'aveu
des tares isation de la police en tout
cas tout le monde vu que j'étais
enceinte
oui donc vous n'avez pas été surpris non
non mais c'est pas la question
en tout cas ce qui est quand même très
étrange c'est que ceux qui m'ont
sollicité sont ceux là même qui m'ont
fait des reproches ensuite et vous qui
avez analysé très récemment dans un
brillant ouvrage le fonctionnement des
médias dans leur vallée soir à bouillon
de culture selon lui que c'est un surnom
j'aurais pu dire non j'aurais pu dire
non mais écoutez moi je
il ya une tendance globale inquiétante
pour les uns normal pour d'autres il ya
une tendance à oudon respect grandissant
de la vie privée oui est ce que des gens
qui sont sous les feux de la rampe comme
un ministre oui
neuner alimente pas cette tendance en se
prêtant pour des raisons qu'on comprend
pas bien ou plutôt qu'on comprend
parfois hors se prétend ce petit jeu la
question mérite d'être posée je me la
suis posée quand j'ai eu vent toutes les
réactions n'a plus répondu quoi
la réponse est difficile à oopa l'arrêt
non je n'ai pas regretté
je n'ai pas regretté je vais vous dire
pourquoi je n'ai pas regretté parce que
je pense aussi que y'en a assez de ne
pas pouvoir concilier dans ce pays la
maternité et la vie professionnelle et
que finalement montré au pays qu'il est
possible de concilier la maternité et la
vie professionnelle
c'est aussi un message essentiel qu'il
faut donner au pays
et vous croyez alors on me dit mais vous
êtes une super bowl non je ne suis pas
une super woman oui j'ai été fatigué oui
j'ai le b
blues comme toutes les femmes mon tort
c'est peut-être justement de ne pas
aller dire à tes vire je suis fatigué de
baby boom à ce moment là qu aurait dit
la presse jeudi mais de quoi elle se
plaint celle là vous croyez qu'une femme
d'agriculteur quand elle rentre chez
elle elle se met dans une chaise longue
vous croyez qu'une femme de d'ouvriers
ou d'employés qui rentrent chez elles
qui a deux gosses à la maison le mari
elle se remet pas à faire les courses et
le travail
donc qu'est ce que c'est que cette idée
que les femmes qui sont enceintes n'ont
plus le droit de travailler ou de
cogiter avec leur tête c'est pas
acceptable quand même des procès
d'intention pareil
bon mais voilà voilà l'explication
donnée l'occasion que je voulais vous
donner sur une autre chose qui a qui
alloue des pas où vous n'êtes pas
concerné directement qui a agité un peu
le les gens ces dernières semaines
qu'est ce que est ce que vous avez
exposé de choquer par madonna choqué
intrigué c'est très intriguée par
madonna socke et non dans le crime est
incertain dans certains journaux qui
sont qui traînent sur les tables
familiales des photos qui peuvent prêter
vente ouvert la voie bien pire la
télévision je vais vous dire donc c'est
pas les jambes en l'air de madonna qui
vont émoustillé la france entière
non ce qui m'étonne c'est le contraste
entre cette poupée autrichienne telle
qu'elle est apparue la télévision est
effectivement toute sa médiatisation de
sex-symbol ça c'est très étrange
sentiment qu'elle joue avec nous dont je
sais pas de toute façon c'est pas mon
sujet je veux dire par là je regarde ça
comme une curiosité
alors justement votre sujet arrivons
devant vous venez d'évoquer vous avez
fait il ya quelques années un livre qui
a fait parler de lui qui s'appelle le
bébé a peur et ont ras le bol des bébés
à urdorf zh et d'ennui avec l'académie
française à ce propos là parce que vous
savez qu'elle vient de chercher des
noises à la sécurité sociale pour ça
craint on a vu neiger j'avais été
sélectionnée pour le
le prix des essais de l'académie
français et j'ai été éliminé à cause du
titre
alors s'il n'était pas en bon dans ses
livres vous partez en guerre contre les
dangers pour les enfants notamment
principalement de la violence du sexe à
la télévision est ce que depuis ce livre
qui doté de trois ans une 89 4 ans
est-ce que ça fait des progrès
écoutez je vais vous dire j'ai un gros
problème c'est vraiment je n'ai plus le
temps du tout d'en garder une vision
s'abattent depuis longtemps parce que ça
évolue ça évolue très vite la télévision
moi je pense oui je pense que ça évolue
très vite en tout cas ce que je crois
c'est qu'il y a là aussi une écologie de
la communication sur lesquels on devrait
réfléchir car on n'a pas le droit non
plus compte tenu de l'impact que qu'à la
télévision même par rapport à l'école
puisque un enfant passe autant de temps
devant la télévision qu'à l'école on n'a
pas le droit de laisser fonctionner la
télévision sur les règles du marché les
règles du profit la rentabilité de la
pub pour les jouets etc
et chacun sait que ce qui attire l'oeil
à l'enfance et la violence c'est ce qui
le choque c'est comme un adulte
finalement est peut-être encore plus
fortement sur un enfant donc je crois
que ça c'est pas acceptable si vous
voulez qu'il y ait pas une sorte de
l'écologie de l'environnement mais je
pense que globalement ça s'est plutôt
améliorée parce qu'il ya une pression
forte de locuteurs le bébé madonna la
violence à la télévision une norme bien
sûr bon on peut avoir la question va
peut-être vous étonner
on peut avoir l'impression que en dehors
de l'environnement et l'écologie dans ne
leur parlez vous incarnez un peu un
jalon de de valeur à la fois familial et
morale est-ce que vous acceptez ça oui
est ce que vous seriez la version de
gauche du combat pour les valeurs de
philippe de villiers tout pas surtout
pas surtout pas parce que je pense que
au fond elle avait la vie familiale n'a
pas être exploité en politique je veux
dire par là que chacun construit son
bonheur comme il comme il le pense
avec la liberté des moeurs qui le
souhaitent moi je souhaitais avoir
quatre enfants parce que je viens d'une
famille nombreuse
et que j'aurai pas imaginer ma vie sans
enfants mais on peut être très heureux
sans enfant on peut être très heureux
mariés et non mariés vivent en couple
non en couple changeant de partenaire ne
changeant pas de partenaire je crois que
ce qui est très important sur respecter
les libertés ce que philippe de villiers
s'est des leçons de morale en disant il
faut se comporter comme ceci il faut
faire cela personne est allé voir
d'ailleurs dans sa propre vie s'il
respectait les leçons de morale qu'ils
donnaient aux autres donc moi je me
garderai bien de faire des leçons de
morale je respecte le bonheur c'est
quelque chose de fragile où on m'a
traitée de super woman mais vous savez
tout cela est très fragile il suffit que
j'ai un enfant qui qui qui tombe
gravement malade et pour moi le choix
est fait je m'occuperai de lui et
j'arrêterai la politique donc tous ces
équilibres là sont extrêmement fragiles
et c'est surtout pas aux hommes
politiques de donner des leçons sur
l'organisation de la vie privée or ces
dernières semaines on est encore
avant-hier donc tout récemment en a
assisté à une recrudescence des
violences dans un nombre de banlieue oui
alors on ne va pas parler du problème
des banlieues on en a parlé à cette
émission avec d'autres personnalités
mais vous devez savoir c'est il y as
depuis quelques temps un certain nombre
de maires de gauche ou de droite
tendances politiques qui considèrent qu'
on n'a probablement pas été assez
répressif contre les bandes de casseurs
est ce que c'est quelque chose dans la
vie que vous partagez
c'est difficile de trancher de cette
façon là mais en tout cas c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet majeur de société ce
problème de la vie dans les banlieues il
rejoint d'ailleurs les problèmes
d'environnement moi j'essaye de m'y
atteler autant que je peux à la tête du
ministère de l'environnement et en
mettant en place des chartes de
l'écologie urbaine qui sont là que j'ai
je vais lancer l'écologie urbaine la
qualité de la vie les territoires parce
qu'on en revient à ce problème là ce
problème d'équilibré et à ce problème de
la transparence de la façon dont les
citoyens participent au choix qui sont
les leurs donc c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas de réponse toute faite je pense
qu'il faut que nous y réfléchissions
nous allons y réfléchir dans l'est dans
le groupe témoin justement tous ces
problèmes là nous devons aller aux pros
en profondeur des choses ne plus tranché
les problèmes par des principes ou des
yaka je crois que tout doit être remis
sur la table est d'abord ce problème là
il ya un philosophe luc ferry qui vient
de publier un ouvrage qui s'appelle le
nouvel ordre écologique et qui met en
garde contre ce qu'ils appellent de
croiser l'intégrisme écologique
c'est-à-dire ceux qui font passer la
nature avant tout et même avant l'homme
est qui qui vont jusqu'à demander que
l'on reconnaisse des droits à la nature
et aux animaux aux dents est ce que
cette espèce de d'intégrisme écologique
vous inquiètent ils m'inquiètent non
mais il faut s'en garder c'est à dire
que l'intégrisme écologique peut
conduire à de mauvaises décisions c'est
à dire effectivement à quoi servirait-il
de protéger telle ou telle espèce
animale si c'était aux dépens de la
présence humaine
même chose pour la protection des
paysages ou de la nature
si je veux me lancer dans une politique
de reconquête des paysages c'est pour
maintenir les hommes c'est pour que le
paysage soit un outil de travail pour
l'activer au logement pour la beauté
abstraite du paysage mais de cette
idéologie que le losc a une influence en
france sur les mouvements écologistes
oui je pense qu'elle est présente dans
les mouvements écologistes
mais finalement elle sert aussi
d'aiguillon car sur la protection des
espèces est important aussi de protéger
les espèces
d'ailleurs au sommet de la planète terre
à rio nous avons décidé par la
biodiversité la protection des espèces
mais il faut toujours garder à l'esprit
que si l'on protège les espèces donc le
patrimoine de la faune et de la flore
c'est aussi parce que ça fait c'est un
enjeu majeur pour l' équilibre du
patrimoine naturel donc des hommes qui
habitent ce patrimoine naturel et à rio
il ya eu cette phrase terrible du
président pakistanais qui est le
président des pays pauvres disons pour
simplifier et qui disait ceci mais
comment voulez vous qu'un homme du
tiers-monde qui est assis sur un tas
d'ordure puisse s'intéresser à l'oiseau
qui vole au dessus de lui
c'est sale
l'écologie responsable c'est de se dire
éliminant d'abord les déchets sur lequel
vit cet homme à porte en lui de l'eau
potable et c'est comme cela aussi que
l'on sauvera l'oiseau qui est au dessus
de lui mais pas l' inverse ne commençons
pas sauvé l'oiseau avant de donner de
l'eau potable à l'homme qui est en
dessous l'oiseau est ce qu'il n'ya pas
est ce qu'on n'est pas dans une à une
époque où il ya un choix terrible
impossible à faire cette montée de la de
la préoccupation sur l'environnement
tout à fait légitime interviennent dans
les pays développés les pays développés
juste un moment où il ya une crise de
croissance terrible est où le problème
du chômage on sait ce que c'est chez
nous où le plein de chômage se pose
d'une façon très aiguë est ce qu'il n'ya
pas un conflit qui n'est pas soluble
entre les deux la préoccupation de
l'environnement et la préoccupation de
l'emploi si une logique écologique et
noël logique productiviste dissin il ya
un conflit qui sera de plus en plus
dures au fur et à mesure que la cie la
crise économique continue ce conflit
sera de plus en plus dur c'est ce qui
m'inquiète d'ailleurs car le conflit
il est entre eux les échéances
immédiates à court terme on le voit bien
lorsque l'on dit l entreprise écoutez
vous polluez vous avez sali cette
rivière il faudra des siècles pour la
reconquérir pour nettoyer les
appelations elodie m'écouter moi je suis
là ça que je licencie salariés et alors
qu'est ce que ce chantage là on lan
permanent émois amoureux de mise en
environnement c'est de tenir bon sur le
long terme c'est de dire écoutez si vous
faites cet effort là il y aura peut-être
un coup transitoire mais ensuite vous
deviendrez aussi plus compétitif et
chiaki s'il ya quelqu'un dans vingt ou
un certain nombre de gens dans un bourg
de bretagne où des deux sèvres qui
défilent dans la rue avec des panneaux
disant ségolène royal
responsable de la perte de nos emplois
je pense que l'environnement si elle est
si la politique de l'environnement est
bien suivie elle peut à la fois protéger
les emplois et protéger l'avenir
c'est ça le mans ce défi protéger les
emplois parce que nous avons aussi les
moyens d'aider les entreprises à se
remettre aux normes
nous avons les agences de
l'environnement le ministère de
l'environnement y est donc nous devons
wii ou la condition que oui atelier vous
le seul ministre contente son budget oui
je suis contente de mon budget ça avoir
des taux n'est pas ce que je fais je
peux faire beaucoup avec ce budget là
pourquoi parce que l'environnement là un
franc donné dans l'environnement fait un
effet de levier considérable
il ya haumea francilienne entreprises
qui polluent que je veux aider à
dépolluer jeudi à la collectivité
territoriale il faut l'aider aussi jeudi
à l'entreprise était vous aussi jeudi à
la région et des aussi entrepris jeudi à
l'europe aidée aussi l'entreprise et
donc à partir du moment où le ministère
de l'environnement cautionne une action
il ya une multitude de cofinancement qui
arrive sur cette opération là et les
emplois on les sauvera et
l'environnement en même temps on
arrivera à le protéger
c'est ça le défi majeur aujourd'hui
c'est ça la social écologie c'est de
sauver à la fois l'emploi et en même
temps pour les générations d'aujourd'hui
et l'environnement pour les générations
futures donc l'emploi pour les
générations futures
car si aujourd'hui la croissance ne
s'appuie pas sur la protection de
l'environnement
ce ne sera pas une croissance durable
donc le défilé majeur car ce seront les
générations de demain qui devront payer
le nettoyage de la rivière polluée
le nettoyage de la nappe phréatique
polluer dont elles ne pourront pas créer
les emplois nécessaires
tout l'argent sera mis pour dépolluer ce
que ceux qui sont qui ont été là avant
on fait donc protéger les emplois du
futur c'est lutter aujourd'hui pour la
protection de l'environnement dernière
question
on est à l'époque du salon de l'auto
dans le sondage du journal du dimanche
dont parlait france henry tout à l'heure
il ya une question où on demandait ce
que vous êtes d'accord pour qui les
nouvelles restrictions à la circulation
des voitures en ville il ya trois quarts
des français qui disent oui nous sommes
d'accord pour le nouvelles restrictions
oui est ce que vous croyez cette
proportion c'est énorme et c'est très
nouveau ce que je crois que les français
aiment beaucoup leur voiture mais que la
voiture des autres les jeunes beaucoup
mais que ça non mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut rien faire et quand j'ai fait
la fête de la planète à propos de rio
que j'appelais tous les maires des
grandes villes
jacques chirac et tous les autres maires
bordeaux marseille lille toulouse tous
les maires ont dit banco ont fait une
journée sans voiture c'est comme ça
qu'on a vu boulevard saint-germain sans
voiture avec plus de cent mille
personnes descendre dans la rue
je crois que la reconquête de l'espace
urbain c'est aussi une poly indécis
majeur pour l'environnement c'est une de
mes priorités la reconquête de l'espace
urbain faire des sites propres
développer les transports collectifs
haut de gamme de qualité où les gens ont
du confort et à ce moment là quand il
sera plus aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se
passe quand il ya un embouteillage on
est plus on est mieux dans sa voiture
que dans le bus coincés dans le mêmes
embouteillages
à partir de là c'est pas possible le
combat entre la voiture et le transport
collectif est inégal
forcément c'est la voiture qui gagne
quand on arrivera la changer ça qu'on
sera mieux installés dans un transport
collectif à ce qui leur à pas il n'y
aura pas d'embouteillages que dans une
voiture où il ya un embouteillage à ce
moment là on aura gagné
autre sujet il ya 3 4 ans vous êtes
parti en guerre contre l'heure d'été
vous êtes devenus ministres députés
ministres terra et puis l'heure d'été ou
de leur gaieté l'heure d'hiver est
toujours là et oui votre efficacité peut
être mise en doute l'un oui oui mais
c'est pas pour ça que je vais jouer
abandonné le vrai problème c'est qu en
gros le pin ans partagent en deux c'est
à dire autant de français sont
favorables autant de français sont
défavorables aux de problème c'est que
la france qui en 1976 a eu cette idée
absurde de changer leur dire de dire au
soleil on va on va prendre un décret
pour dire au soleil à quelle heure ils
se couchent qui était imité par tout le
monde et qui a été imité par tout le
monde
un matin un complexe au plan
international qu'est ce qui bloque
aujourd'hui ce sont les diplomates qui
bloque en disant mais comment
ayant le sens du ridicule on va pas
revenir au plan européen en disant on
s'est trompé en 76 maintenant tout le
monde fait marche arrière mais je n'ai
pas désespérer rendez vous en mars
prochain ce sera dur mais j'y arriverai
peut-être il ya d'autres est ce que
c'est en mars que changent leur donnons
l'air s'était pas à propos d'un autre
rendez vous là je note simplement et
madame que parmi elles vos deux
priorités protéger des paysages lutter
contre le bruit sont les deux priorités
de votre action vienne que sondage pour
sondages viennent en queue du sondage du
journal du dimanche
ipsos dans les préoccupations sais pas
mais c'est difficile car si vous lisez
les lie au dessus reconquérir les
rivières c'est le paysage promettent des
espaces verts en ville c'est le paysage
donc si vous faites la somme de tout ce
qui se rattache au paysage et le bruit
se rattache aux paysages comment voulez
vous regardez un paysage s'il ya du
bruit et ses deux priorités la le
paysage et le bruit interviennent
peut-être pas au même titre que les
déchets mais les français ont répondu
les déchets parce qu'il y avait une
crise en revanche et deux priorités là
je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai été
choisi parce que c'est là où il ya une
inégalité le plus probable de voir la
qualité mais c'est très important parce
que c'est 10 % la france et qui dit ça
ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux parce
que si on fait la somme ça fait au moins
50% pour les paysages c'est aussi ce qui
probablement se prononce le moins sur
les problèmes d'environnement
merci madame c'était donc l'heure de
vérité de madame ségolène royal ministre
de l'environnement à la veille du
conseil des ministres de l'environnement
des 12 qui va se tenir à luxembourg
mardi rediffusion de cette émission sur
france 2 cette nuit à 1h16 et sur tv5
europe
demain lundi à 11 heures la prochaine
invitée monsieur edouard balladur qui
est auteur de ce livre du dictionnaire
de la réforme à paraître chez fayard
et alors monsieur balladur écrit page 93
et aux mots maux environnementaux mot
écologie mieux sanctionner les
infractions édictée dès obligations
nouvelles c'est bien mais il faudrait
surtout faciliter la création
d'associations qui équilibre et la
puissance des administrations et des
entreprises
c'est ce qu'à votre avis c'est
l'essentiel oui sauf que les
associations n'ont pas besoin de la
permission de monsieur balladur pour se
constituer
heureusement
il ya déjà des décennies qu'elle existe
dans ce pays et grâce à elle d'ailleurs
l'environnement fut beaucoup progrès
merci madame dans six minutes le journal
présenté par hervé claude de bon appétit
à tous et bon dimanche
[Musique]